[Music]
let's watch a little bit of dana white
oh yeah our own complex yeah i'm here to
buy uh
sneakers made by chinese kids yeah i
think it's awesome that they can use
kids to make shoes
[Music]
in las vegas the city that never sleeps
there's one man
who needs shoes
dana white
lex luthor himself
the man the myth the legend
dana white nobody knows you're the
you're literally the first like how he
pointed in the air there
ufc president
number one the big man upstairs dana
white
know that the steel is done gonna do
some sneaker shopping today to see what
he's feeling what he's not and then
hopefully he's gonna buy some sneakers
i'm definitely gonna buy some sneakers
let's go
i'm [ __ ] these checks i'm getting
from howlerhead yeah
you bet your ass i'm buying some [ __ ]
speed he's like what are these
reasons at the bottom they're like a
howler head collab
yeah i'm definitely getting these yeah
look there's a happy dad logo on the
back
[Music]
adidas you kind of lived in here for so
long like the gazelles and the sambas
talk about like your love for these
classic adidas yeah i've always loved
the adidas you know i have a huge
collection and for a while there you
could uh custom make they have this
thing where you can custom make them
you're just explaining the internet
you go on i believe it's adidas.com
customize yeah
that's the url you type that in and it's
actually quicker because if you go to
the main website you have to like find
the shoe and click but if you enter that
url you actually get to take you
straight there and you can customize
yeah that's why they named it that yeah
so i would customize all of my favorite
shoes it's pretty cool you know it's
like a little 3d model and then you can
kind of select the area in which you're
customizing so you can do blue for the
front and then all you got to do is
click on the back and you can customize
the back as well yeah pump out a few
pairs a month you go online and like
i love how he says that like he's just
going out of control
yeah he's customizing 60 pair of adidas
i might buy two or three if i'm feeling
crazy a month
a month dude design exactly yeah i
remember like even weigh-ins from like
2008 it would always be these gazelles
the suede 100 these these are actually
this one here and then i customized
those myself
it was a black shoe and then white lines
so did that all on the website which was
uh adidas.com customize and what's funny
is uh you know normally you know because
i always thought adidas came a white
shoe with black lines so then i went to
customize it black with what but then
someone told me later that it actually
already existed black and white so
no they kind of stole that from me oh
yeah there it is actually yeah these are
pretty cool
is it the love of like classic footwear
that you used to see when you were like
training at the boxing gym we grew up
wearing those okay and that was you know
i mean the whole era where i love this
like every old person is like yeah well
when we were growing up there were only
five shoes yeah
you had running shoes
walking shoes
basketball shoes
and then mom shoes
and then gardening shoes it was uh these
and a champion hoodie yeah i mean when i
lived in boston so i've always loved
adidas i've always loved the look of the
shoe the feel of it it's one of my
all-time favorites and then what are
like your shopping habits when it comes
to sneakers you just said off camera
that you're you have to like rebuild the
closet because it's getting so many are
you shopping for sneakers a lot you sent
people do you have a plug or what yeah
you know i i look for
for new cool stuff stuff that's hard to
get honestly probably by 10 to 15 pairs
a month really yeah dana you have a
problem yeah seriously dude
it'd be so funny if you bought three
pairs of adidas oh he did
what if it's just like it's like 140
bucks yeah he's like yeah we're gonna
run the card
getting pretty wild okay here we go we
got this we got some
yup i appreciate it
thank you
adidas gazelle navy 80 bucks
[Music]
is this the most regular shoes it really
is they gave him some undefeated dunk
gloves nice he spent 455
if i ever got invited on this show i'd
be like
i think i'm just gonna take one pair
i'd find the cheapest pair yeah you have
clearance yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
where's the sail rack yeah 40 sandals
you just get some rainbow flip-flops
yeah [ __ ] outlet edition yeah air
jordan i need some new shower shoes
for the gym what a what a guy man that's
i love that show because when they
started it
they're like we can get all kinds of
crazy guests on here
and now you know every day they're like
kind of struggling they're like well who
the [ __ ] can we get what else gives a
[ __ ] about shoes
dana white he's always wearing those
[ __ ] adidas right business guys on
this show is so funny they're just gonna
get like imagine a year from now and
they're getting like silicon valley guys
oh they'd be so funny
well typically i just wear one pair of
new balance for the year yeah yeah i
just want to limit my
uh my clothing uh options is actually
just this outfit yeah and i have a
perpetual steam room for my clothes so
i'm always wearing one outfit
i was like really you don't have
anything else no do you have any stories
about shoes oh clothes are really
uninspiring to me yeah i've never felt
like expressing myself ever through
fashion i don't understand it i do it
through code it's a waste of materials
yeah uh frankly one day we're not gonna
need clothes that's the future we're
working towards yeah so one day a shop
like this won't exist yeah and then and
then they start doing uh wall street
guys yeah they're in nordstrom yeah and
they're like looking for new loafers
yeah it's like so tell me about tell me
about these tom ford loafers what do you
like about these and and how do you
connect to them to be honest i don't
really um it's just kind of a standard
when you work on wall street you kind of
have to look the look i spilled a bag of
coke on mine last night and uh we're
kind of buttoning down the firm we don't
want to be too out in the open without
i'm i'm uh actually going to visit my
in-laws uh in connecticut and i'm scared
about the bomb dog at the airport
there's always one there and he might
smell the coke on the shoes so i got to
get more sucks because you know how to
take a scheduled flight normally i fly
private yeah
yeah today i'm flying business ugh but
yeah tom for a great guy i've met him i
know his family
my family um i go way back with the
fords yeah both they're good people it's
a good product and the fashion yeah okay
who else could be on that show that
would just be the worst they try to get
weirder they invite like some monks on
they don't even wear shoes yeah how
would you rate these shoes that's really
good beautiful but we have no feelings
towards them yeah sick
that's tight
it would be awesome actually if they
just pivoted and didn't do celebrities
and they just took dudes from complex
con all the spiderweb guys yeah what the
[ __ ] does he think about that oh my god
because honestly i think virgil ablo is
mid
oh jesus they're like okay buddy oh god
all right buddy all right man all the
[ __ ] that virgil did i was already doing
uh okay
all right yup
and we're really out here man we're
really doing this [ __ ] really doing this
[ __ ] my buddy and i million dollar drop
drop shipping shopify
you